let's talk a little bit about the short
run and long run phillips curve
now they're named after the economist
bill phillips who saw in the 1950s what
looked like an inverse relationship
between inflation and the unemployment
rate and he was studying decades of data
sets in the united kingdom where he saw
usually when we had high or when the
united kingdom had high inflation you
had relatively low unemployment and that
tended to be when the economy was doing
well so he would see these data points
from different years and then he would
see that when there was a high
unemployment rate when the economy was a
little bit slower
then you had low inflation and so he
theorized the existence of a curve that
could describe this relationship maybe
it looks something
like this
and if we take this model or if we
assume this model then it would hold
that when the economy is strong you have
high inflation low unemployment when the
economy is weak you have high
unemployment and low inflation
now you fast forward to the 1970s and
economists started to see a situation
where this broke down in the 1970s in
particular you saw situations of stag
flation where you had both high
unemployment and high inflation so it
didn't seem to fit the phillips curve
and so economists theorized that okay
maybe this thing that phillips theorized
is really just what happens in the short
run so they said that this is the short
run phillips curve but they theorize
that there's actually a long run
phillips curve as well that describes
the natural rate of unemployment or the
natural rate of unemployment you would
get when the economy is at full
employment
and remember full employment doesn't
mean everyone's employed it just means
the sustainable rate of employment for
the country
and so if we wanted to draw that long
run phillips curve that economists
theorized in the 1970s it might look
something like this
and when you see it as a vertical line
like this let me write this long
run
phillips curve it shows that over the
long run the unemployment rate would be
this value right over here irrespective
of what's going on with inflation and so
let's say for this economy our natural
rate of unemployment is
four percent
and we see that it is associated with
one percent inflation
and so you could imagine if there are
some perturbations to the economy maybe
the economy gets a little bit overheated
well then you could get a little bit
higher inflation and lower unemployment
or if the economy slows down a little
bit you could have higher unemployment
and lower inflation but it should
gravitate back to the long run phillips
curve
but now let's think about this in
context of our aggregate demand
aggregate supply model and think about a
scenario where our short run phillips
curve could actually shift
so here we have our typical axes when
we're thinking about aggregate demand
and aggregate supply we have real gdp on
our horizontal axis the price level on
our vertical axis and so our aggregate
demand curve might look something like
this it is downward sloping so let's
call that our aggregate demand curve and
then our short run aggregate supply
curve
might look something like this
so as price levels go up in the short
run people are going willing to produce
more
so this is our short run
aggregate supply and remember when we
talked about aggregate demand and
aggregate supply we talked about a
notion of our full employment output
which is you could view as the
sustainable rate of output for an
economy
and we can draw that as a vertical line
so this right over here
would be
our long run
aggregate supply
and where it intersects our real gdp
axis this is our full employment output
if you want to put some numbers on it
maybe this is equal to for a small
economy maybe this is equal to 50
billion dollars
so the way we've just described this
we are at equilibrium right now we're at
full employment output our economy is
producing 50 billion dollars per year
and our full employment output implies
an unemployment rate of four percent
where we have one percent inflation
now let's say that there's some type of
a demand shock let's say all of a sudden
the government wants to stimulate the
economy even beyond where it is here and
so you have a and so they start spending
all of this money and so you have a
shift in the aggregate demand curve so
it would shift to the right so the
aggregate demand curve would now look
something like this let's call that
aggregate demand 2.
well what happens now and we've seen
this in previous videos
now you have we go from this equilibrium
point which was at this full employment
output and at this price level let's
call that
price level one and now we're at this
equilibrium point people are demanding
more so suppliers say hey if you want me
to produce more i'm going to charge you
some more for it too so our price level
has gone up
we are at price
level 2
and we are producing above full
employment output maybe this level right
here is 60 billion well how would that
be reflected on our phillips curves
well in the short run our economy has
gotten a little bit above potential so
in the short run so we would sit on the
short run phillips curve and our
unemployment rate would go down but if
we assume the phillips curve the short
run phillips curve model that means our
inflation would go up
so this point right over here might
correspond maybe to
this point
right over there
where when we get to that beyond full
employment output let's say that this is
60 billion
right over here
well maybe our unemployment rate
is 2
and our inflation rate here is three
percent
now what happens next well we've talked
about this when we studied aggregate
demand and aggregate supply
workers when it's time for them to
renegotiate their contracts will say hey
prices have gone up i'm not going
willing to work for the same amounts
over the long run and so you have a
shift to the left of the aggregate
supply curve at any given price level
there's going to be less supply less
output and so if this shifts to the left
eventually the equilibrium point will go
back to where everything intersects with
the long run aggregate supply curve
so the short run aggregate supply curve
shifts over there and then we would be
back to our full employment output
although our price level would have gone
even higher price level three
now many economists would argue that
when you have a shift in the short run
aggregate supply so this would be short
run
aggregate supply
that that also is associated with a
shift in our short run phillips curve
because of these price increases and
because workers have are trying to
renegotiate their salaries upwards and
labor is the biggest factor in price
levels you might have increased
inflation expectations so in a given
rate of inflation you would you might
start having a higher unemployment and
so this short run phillips curve could
shift to the right so instead of this
just gravitating back to where it was
before the whole curve could shift to
the right and we get to a situation
that looks like this
where our inflation is still at three
percent but we are back to the long run
unemployment rate of this economy